[Music]
Trump gay marriage women on boards black
lives matter what do they have in common
they've all been used as examples of
so-called identity politics it's the
idea that groups are calling for special
treatment based on race religion sex or
other characteristics and some fear that
a politics based of protecting narrow
group interests rather than broader
political movements can be dangerous
identity politics emerged because groups
that have been historically ignored or
harmed demanded their right to be
protected from civil rights or women's
rights to gay rights the idea was that
safeguarding these rights make society
fairer more tolerant and more equal but
some now think that these protections
have gone too far by focusing so much on
their own rights and interests they
threaten the rights of others if you
oppose affirmative action you may be
labeled a racist if you comment on a
woman's appearance you might be called a
misogynist or a sex pest the belief that
political correctness has gone too far
fuel the rise of Trump whose campaign
was naked Leon PC and this isn't just a
Western phenomenon either nor is it new
India's ruling party espouses Hindu
nationalism
sometimes at the expense of the
country's Muslim minority so identity as
part of politics everywhere and probably
always will be but there is a way
forward and it starts with resisting the
temptation to see politics as a zero-sum
game
if the LGBT community gets more rights
or protections heterosexuals don't
automatically get fewer supporting
women's interest doesn't simultaneously
undermine the interest of men so the
question is not whether
identity politics should exist but in
what form knee-jerk actions or quick
fixes like quotas aren't the best way to
go but there is a role for better
information such as improving public
date on diversity in companies or
universities
the challenge is to make identity
politics constructive and inclusive
rather than destructive and divisive
open not closed
you